[MUSIC PLAYING]
>> So why would someone like me get involved
with a campaign to end
female genital mutilation?
I, first of all, became a freelancer but then
went off and did VSO
with -- firstly in Cambodia and last year
I'd went to Ethiopia.
I had got this impression of Africa that I'd
seen in the movies.
And -- which was full of joyous women.
I suppose very stereotypical.
And Ethiopia was just -- so different.
There were so many confusing mixed messages.
So yes, women were incredibly beautiful and
amazing awesome dignity,
but that joyousness I didn't find and I sort
of expected to.
And so I started asking around a bit more
about women's issues.
I learned a little bit of Amharic, so I was
able to interact with women
a little bit.
But a women took me to one side one day and
you said, you do realize
women in Ethiopia are cut.
And that euphemism meant nothing to me.
No, I didn't realize.
And I started to explore a bit more and that
was when I discovered
really what "cut" meant, which means that
their external genitals are
cut out basically.
That was one moment I remember very clearly
in my journey.
The second moment was meeting an amazing woman
-- who's been
campaigning for 60 years on this -- and asking
her, do I have a
mandate to do this?
Because I was getting scared.
As a woman from the West, you know, what right
do I have to basically
practice what is known everywhere was cultural
imperialism.
Cultural relativism, putting my view onto
whole entire countries and
communities.
And she sat me down and looked at me and she
said, would you campaign
against torture?
And I said, well, yeah.
She said, well can a white man campaign against
torture of black women?
And I said yes, of course.
And she said, well, that's what you're doing.
This voice needs to be heard.
You've got to be heard.
And in that moment, it was if I had a blessing,
as if I had a sanction
from someone who was right in the thick of
this debate.
As if she said go forth and do what you can,
bring this issue out in
the open, break the taboo, break the silence.
And do something about it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]